Bobby misery is only feminism can
deliver
[Music]
it is said that hurt people hurt people
no statement could some of the ideology
of modern feminism better and no movie
does as good a job of illustrating this
warped worldview than Barbie the central
destructive notion of liberalism is the
idea that we're all individuals
maximizing our freedom and pursuing
happiness I have much sympathy for this
approach when it comes to relations
between the citizen and the government I
am liberal in the sense that I want to
be freed from authoritarian control in
order to be able to pursue my own
happiness as I see fit what I believe
liberalism gets wrong is the attempt to
apply this concept outside of the
relationship between the individual and
the state and extend it into the realm
of family and human relations more
broadly yes freedom from intrusive
government is likely to provide
opportunities for each individual to
pursue their own happiness but it is
simply a lie to say that maximizing
freedom from your fellow human beings is
a recipe for happiness this is why smart
feminists like my friend Louise Perry
are now making precisely the opposite
argument in writing her last book the
case against the sexual Revolution Perry
said that as a feminist the best advice
she can offer young women is to quote
get married and do your best to stay
married in other words happiness is
derived not from your freedom from other
people but from the bonds you form with
them indeed as any parent knows the most
meaningful things we ever get to do are
the very things that constrain our
freedom the most the Barbie wasn't made
by smart feminists and it shows if the
poison pill of hyper liberalism is to
encourage us to see ourselves as
atomized individuals the liberal
feminism of Hollywood depicted here is
worse still you're not actually free to
pursue your happiness by yourself says
Barbie because you live in a world which
is run by one of two competing gangs in
Barbie land the protagonist lives in a
magical realm surrounded by fellow dolls
this section of the movie which looks
like a diversity consultant threw up
over a casting shortlist is best enjoyed
as unintentional satire of a world
without men the female dolls take out
the trash and pretty pink bins while
wearing mini skirts there's no running
water and the various models of Ken the
men of this magic land such as they are
are neutered and relegated to their
rightful place the sidelines the Supreme
Court is obviously all female so is the
president she wears a sash like a beauty
pageant winner for extra gravitas when
Barbie is forced by a contrived set of
circumstances to travel into the real
world she and her loser accomplice Ken
all the men in this movie are losers
discover that things are exactly the
other way around man in the real world
Ogle women slap their asses and drive
big black cars boo Barbie goes from
matriarchy to patriarchy and boy does
she hate it Ken on the other hand snort
slap patriarchy right up both nostrils
and returns to Barbie land to make it
some sort of deranged teenage boy's
Dream House complete with mini fridges
table football and songs about keeping
women down that my friends is the choice
says Barbie
matriarchy or patriarchy pick your
Champion the modern feminist movement is
intent on brainwashing young women and
increasingly the rest of us to see the
relationship between men and women as
one of competition the insanity of this
world view of the fact that it is
increasingly making women miserable is
by the by for the ideologues who are
advancing it but fear not but Bobby has
the solution when she returns to the
Barbie land Kent has now ruined with his
toxic masculinity Barbie and her fellow
plastic girl bosses work out what to do
they must use the ego hubris and
stupidity of men against them once the
humiliation is complete the men stop
oppressing women and instead cry talk
about their feelings and do all the
other things men need to do to be better
because as we all know the way for meant
to be better is for them to be more like
women because women are equal to men and
better too in any case having retaken
Barbie land from the clutches of the
patriarchy and rejected Ken's quite
reasonable suggestion that he and Bobby
I.E men and women are created to be
together Barbies free to ride off until
the sunset alone no one tells her the
what a waiter at the conclusion of her
journey of empowerment is cats wine and
misery well why would they feminists
want other women to make the same
mistakes they did Misery Loves Company
in a perfect metaphor for modernity the
marketing budget for Barbie is bigger
than the production budget for the movie
itself why make a good product when you
can just make it shiny start a buzz and
hire a famous hot woman to front it for
feminism
myself
[Music]
you guys ever think about dying